i like dallas dallas showed up man i
almost lost sleep last night because i
was worried that she was going to do old
dallas where she takes forever to ramp
up yeah now the switch is turned on man
i'm so impressed by kaia these days
because when we did coaching she
couldn't do vibrato she couldn't do runs
but what i like about kaya is this
kinley disappointed me yeah
i can't wait time's not working i think
something's really getting her head i'm
biased because she's like my star of the
dance
just didn't happen
[Music]
all right here's the situation
this was tough
it was as hard as like an
elimination so let's get to the exciting
part the first verse
is going to dallas
second verse
is going to kaia
and the wrap
is going to brooklyn
be happy for your friends and good job
you guys
i worked really hard for it you know i'm
the rapper of the group and it's just
you know not
so pleasant to see somebody just
take it away from you like it's
easy
i don't know why they didn't think that
i was very good and i don't want to be
the person who gets left behind
i can tell y'all are a little
disappointed but it's okay guys y'all
did a great job it doesn't mean you're
going home this week but you do have to
go to rehearsal and kill this dance
because that's all that she's going to
have to judge you on this week
[Music]
you